ugly depressing a cross between a giant
square box and a federal penitentiary
these are all ways that people have
described this building behind me it's
Evans Hall at the University of
California Berkeley it's built in a
style of architecture called brutalism
and when you look at college campuses
around the US you'll see brutalist
architecture like this everywhere why
are there so many brutalist buildings on
campuses and what about this style of
architecture makes it so
divisive
okay just to start with the name
brutalism doesn't actually have anything
to do with the brutality of the
architecture per se although some may
argue that it's quite harsh in
appearance it's actually derived from a
French phrase the B on Brew um the raw
Concrete in French this is Timothy Rowan
he's a professor of architectural
history at UMass Amherst a campus known
for its stunning brutalist architecture
it's also the home of UMass brute a
campus organization that raises
awareness of the school's collection of
buildings some architects in
conversations about brutalism and its
Origins come up a lot one of them is the
Swiss born French architect Lor buus he
built an enormous building in Marse an
apartment building the UN de abito this
really became a model for the use of
concrete and um a model for what became
brutalism concrete was widely used but
some sometimes before this you would
maybe sand the surface paint the surface
clean it up in a groundbreaking fashion
he left the concrete surface raw the
corbusier continued to build on the
motifs he used in UN daion in his later
work other architects of the day played
in the brutalist sandbox as well such as
Marcel Brer Paul Rudolph
hon and Lis Khan Brut ISM became not
just a style of architecture but an
entire aesthetic
ethos in what became a Manifesto of
sorts for the movement architecture
writer and critic rner banam decreed
that new brutalist structures should
have the following qualities one
memorability as an image two clear
exhibition of structure and three
valuation of materials as found
modernist architecture up to this point
was dominated by people like lwig M
vandero who built Sleek glass corporate
skyscrapers which featured what are
called curtain walls non-load bearing
veneers that were meant to hide the
construction some Architects say if you
have a whole city like this it's going
to become benal monotonous modernist
Architects called these buildings
fishbowls and they were lampooned for
their resemblance to graph paper in
contrast brutalist buildings strove for
honesty in their materials and structure
they showed you how they were
constructed
at the end of World War II College
attendants shot up there was the
veterans returning from the war who were
eligible for government benefits that
allowed them to go to college and paid
for it this necessitated that
universities build new facilities to
handle ballooning Admissions and with so
many new buildings being needed what did
architects of the day turn to
[Music]
brutalism sorry schools like Yale had
entire campuses of brutalist
architecture spring up which received
glowing Marquee reviews in the New York
Times campuses across the country
erected some pretty spectacular
buildings that typified the challenging
and idealistic brutalist aesthetic
schools like Harvard UMass Dartmouth UC
San Diego the University of Chicago and
of course Berkeley some of the colleges
like Yale University they wanted toart
from the old models of the gothic and
the Georgia a campus that was like
Oxford or Cambridge for elite gentlemen
now they want to show that they are
becoming a worldclass research
University a university like mine
University of
Massachusetts expanded at this time from
an agricultural college and it becomes a
research University the flagship Campus
of Massachusetts and so they start to
become the hosts for modern architecture
to show their progress during the 1970s
the US economy took a downturn new
construction on campuses ground to a
virtual Halt and maintenance of existing
facilities was neglected leaving many
buildings brutalist and otherwise dingy
and in need of renovation and there's
real cutbacks and maintenance during
the' 70s uh it's noticeable and there's
even a policy that many campuses had
called deferred maintenance we're not
going to do repairs we're not going to
unstop the gutter we're not going to put
in air conditioning that was never
installed
it's deferred for a future dat when will
this dat come I think it's maybe today
the 1980s swept in a new era of
construction that was a definite change
of pace Architects like Robert Venturi
designed University buildings that
featured brighter colors asymmetrical
shapes and playful Design Elements
instead of attempts to preserve or
renovate brutalist buildings in need of
repair numerous campuses across the
country opted to tear them down and
build build something shiny and new and
that is what it seems like will be the
Fate for poor Evans Hall here in
Berkeley although a campus spokesperson
told me that there is quote no project
in the works or approved to demolish
Evans Hall they went on to say that
they're in the process of relocating all
classrooms and offices out of the
building and will then construct new
buildings to house them at which point
they will propose a project to demolish
Evans which sounds to me like they're
going to tear it down the reason for all
of this is a study that showed that its
seismic rating against Earthquakes is
poor so why is there no talk about
tearing down this building or this one
or this one these buildings and over 22
others on campus share the same seismic
rating as Evans so why set your sites on
just Evans it's often about a number of
other considerations like real estate um
the fact that these sites are valuable
space on college campuses is at a
premium the real reason may be buried
further in the report which says that
quote due to its massing height scale
and materiality Evans Hall which
obstructs views to San Francisco and
Beyond is considered in congruous with
the bozarts buildings in the classical
core and that quote the ad hoc placement
of the new buildings lacked sensitivity
my council is be patient um just because
you find something unfashionable at the
moment um doesn't mean you should
eradicate it but while brutalism has
hasn't been seen in a positive light for
a few Generations all hope is not
necessarily lost there does seem to be a
bit of a Renaissance happening Dr Rowan
hopes to spread the gospel of brutalism
to a new generation by doing tours of
the brutalist buildings on the campus of
his university and Zillow has even named
brutalism as one of the top trends to
watch in 2024 when you look around
brutalism influence has actually made
its way into many corners of our culture
there are $1,000 concrete West Elm
coffee tables and Jay-Z and Beyonce paid
$200 million for a brutalist inspired
house on the ocean I think it has seeped
into popular culture through Instagram
through Pinterest all these things it is
the very expressive architecture it
photographs really well it's like cats
on the internet um it just
[Music]
spreads